العلامات الأولى لكارثة روسية تم
وضع علامة z على دبابة روسية تم إنقاذها من قبل
القوات الأوكرانية
قبل أيام قليلة ، كان هذا المشهد على
حافة هذه الغابة الجسور العائمة الروسية
تحت هجوم مدفعي أوكراني شرس ،
يلقي القائد الأوكراني معنا
نظرة إلى السماء وهو ينظر إلى السماء.  بالنسبة
للطائرات بدون طيار الروسية ، هذا ليس مكانًا للرضا عن النفس
، ادعت أوكرانيا وحلف الناتو أن
روسيا عانت بشدة هنا ، حيث قدروا
أن 80 مركبة دمرت وأن
مجموعة قتالية روسية كاملة مؤلفة من ألف رجل
تحطمت ، لذلك نحن الآن على حافة
المنطقة التي يعيش فيها الروس  تم القبض على درع
بعد عبوره النهر العائم ،
يمكنك أن ترى
هنا دبابة مدمرة
بجواره وأنا ناقلة أفراد وإذا نظرنا
إلى أسفل الطريق هنا لدينا
حاملة جنود مدرعة
أخرى وأخرى وأخرى
كان الأوكرانيون قادرين على
قول ذلك نظرًا لتفوقهم في
الاستطلاع والذكاء
لمعرفة أين كان الروس ذاهبون
إلى العبور ثم جلب مستوى مدمر
المدفعية وهذه هي النتيجة ، هذه ليست
سوى حافة روسيا قد حولت الآن
هجماتها إلى مكان آخر على الأقل في الوقت الحالي
عندما ترى هذا كيف تشعر ،
نعم ،
أفهم أن مدفعيتنا
تعمل وأن قواتنا تعمل أيضًا
لأن  كان هناك
قتال مدفعي وأرضي للوحدات بالتعاون
مع قوات أخرى كانوا يدفعون العدو
عبر النهر سيرا على الأقدام
دروع روسية محطمة منتشرة
على طول هذا المسار عبر الغابة
على الأرض لا يمكننا المضي قدما في
المسار الملغومة
كارثة حقيقية  بالنسبة للروس ، لكن
شيئًا ما يقوله الأوكرانيون الآن
هنا يعني أن الضغط
قد توقف عن هذه الجبهة بالذات في الوقت الحالي
وأنهم يعتقدون أن الروس
يركزون جهودهم أكثر في أماكن أخرى.
الحقيقة
هي أن العديد من رفاقهم
قد انتهى بهم الأمر على
هذا النحو ، وبينما يعد هذا نجاحًا في
الحرب الطاحنة لأوكرانيا ، تظل روسيا
تهديدًا فوريًا وطلبوا
منا الخروج من هنا مع
قائدهم العسكري لأنهم
قلقون من أن سياراتنا
ستجذب الانتباه ، وبالتالي فإن
هذا لا يزال من الواضح
أن منطقة نشطة للغاية وواحدة كما
كانت من قبل.  الروس يبعثون
على الارتياح لترك
سام كيلي سي إن إن بيل هاريفكا